he's been called the funniest person of
all time he was nominated four times for
the Academy Awards he was known for his
improvisation skills and the wide
variety of memorable voices that he
created he's Robin Williams and here's
my take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one pursue the moment what is this humor
come from this is somebody wants to
drive this your performance would be
terrific yeah voluntary Tourette's what
is really really know like it is a bit
like that I mean it there is that thing
where I'll cross over the line sometimes
obviously today I did but looked like oh
do stop
that look like we be getting to the
question soon
leave that you know where you go off on
things and you sometimes ago you'll see
a moment you go oh and you just pursue
it and it's like a little bit like
possession and it's yeah it happens once
in a while but ways that the moment just
comes there's a pre-planned ready
you know like today there's a commercial
yeah sequential or it's actually more
like a fractal but then we're getting
even Stephen Hawking's going don't go
there now this house one day hello this
is Stephen Hawking yes I'd like to leave
a message no this is Stephen Hawking
[Music]
if a then two you know you're kind of
you know you jumpstart and go to
different places usually from some weird
synapse fire my rule about to keep going
just keep going find that thing you love
because it's tough work and my father
gave me this advice when I said I wanted
to be an actor he said have a back-up
profession like welding but I think if
you can find that thing that really
gives you joy that'll be it because for
me it's always been comedy and stand-up
and enacting too because of exploring
behavior but it's tough work but it's
and if you can get it even better good
luck
rule number three push the envelope all
the things that that you were honored
for you think the characters like Good
Will Hunting ones yeah Good Will Hunting
with him when the Academy Award for that
is there any place that you want to be I
think that I am right now
it's a good play that's exactly right
you have to me about that just a lot we
all share with no cheer very testify
brother yeah is that feeling of being
you know doing like the stand-ups
combined with one-hour photo insomnia
you know kind of pushing the envelope in
terms of what people perceive I can do
especially in playing a character you
know these darker you know troubled and
in many cases you know nasty vicious and
that helps to just you know push it
through because if you're looking at now
when you want you it's at this age to
say you're playing characters now which
is what I always did was doing before
but now it's a given yeah you're heading
towards gabite I don't you know people
go into hiring a man from the dream well
come on Courtney let him go
but it's that idea of you know playing
these characters and doing this it's
been a great combination like a really
good year to just push the envelope and
I think that's always what I want to do
is to try different things and kind of
always change perceptions and change the
rhythm you could yeah break up it's
merely the rhythm it's basically saying
okay now we hit it in you know there and
then you know hit a little harder and
then back off and then go berserk like
you know with the the stand up which is
just free form and then come back and
play something so controlled like in one
hour photo those are all possible I mean
it I was trained at Juilliard you know I
you know went for three years and left
and then you know went and did stand up
but the stand up was always just kind of
a great release and then still having
that ability to play you know both and
having that that range really helps for
me it's great and you mentioned the
other part having great friends and
family they just make life extraordinary
and a world to still go out and see and
learn about which is the most important
of all rule number four do things out of
love well we're talking well it's not
about the the the choices you've been
making particularly recently and and
what's driving those and you know what
are the boxes that you're taking that
enables you to do something like Paul's
Greatest Dad I mean with that I was just
going it
I knew the but I read it and what I
really want to do this and he sent it to
me just to see if I wanted to play a
small plot to help get him made I went
no I want to play him it'd be great yeah
I mean for me is just to be if it has
something that kind of affects me or
drives me you know some of you should do
for money and those are the dangerous
ones old dog we'll talk later
the idea that you do those and you go
and you know why you're making them it's
a kids comedy you know it's gonna be
silly and you know that's gonna be up
for grabs but with something like those
greatest dad it's like well you do it as
a labor of love and you do with friends
who you feel like you can do it with and
say hey we're both in this together and
that's kind of wonderful that's like
where that's that's the best part
it goes back to dead poet's it goes back
to Fisher King wills Greatest Dad
one-hour photo they're all done with
this kind of love you know you commit to
it you go whatever happens I'm in I'm
proud you know that's the that's the
drill also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link to
join is in the description below
playing these characters and doing this
it's been a great combination like a
really good year to just push the
envelope and I think that's always what
I want to do rule number five develop
your own style I've watched your your
last Broadway show
oh yeah and you'll I live on Broadway
which has been recorded for HBO and we
know there's a truly astonishing
performance because throw me in for two
hours I mean you stand there I don't
think I've know there's no script
there's no prompt there's nothing no you
can't really
we don't tell long anecdotes either me
so quick fire station 1000 different
people because that was all I started
off I start off in a club where it was
usually start off performing in bars
where you can't really take the time
because people go you know are you doing
now don't usually people who own the
club so I started to develop a style
that was just very much like you know
synaptic quickfire moving so they never
really had a chance to lock you know
lock on as a target and then it started
to develop as being this kind of idea of
taking an idea and going with it and
then breaking away and that's been kind
of a style rule number six have idols I
saw you with Jonathan winters oh my god
on David Letterman was clearly a very
strong bonding oh he's the best she's a
wonderful friend and he just had heart
surgery he's doing great he had two
stents put in I called him I said John
how are you I had an operation performed
by Japanese surgeons it was cheaper but
I told him I was in the war they weren't
pleased and whenever I talk to him it's
really wonderful he's the best he's a
for me he's that he's the Buddha he is
the you know the teacher and powerful
influence rule number seven be honest
quiet comedians such complex people I
think that's just that weird thing of
what drives you to do it you know it's
that weird thing of why would you get
out on stage and talk about things and
my favorite comedians that I've ever
seen well is the most honest like Pryor
you know Pryor would be talking about
dying and making it funny and though the
recent kind of in baden-baden end of
that is Chris Rock doesn't it louis c.k
doesn't talks about really painful
things but he's just talking about his
life and but and the idea of going on
stage again I'm gonna talk about really
painful things but let's see if you'd
relate to it and their conflicts because
it's a I think it's a survival mechanism
you know sometimes I did it because it's
one way to get laid sometimes they did
it because it was over it's an outlet
it's you know cheaper than and cheaper
than therapy
and in a weird way they said it said the
things that these things in us you know
spinning inside them that they have to
talk about and it depends on which way
you do it then you know or what drives
rule number eight do interesting work I
don't know how to ask this question but
I'm interesting the answer is it where
do you where are you and where do you
want to go now in terms of this with
whatever new yeah the same I want to
keep doing interesting movies like this
and you know I'm I'm 51 so I'm in
getting towards Walter Brennan right but
I want to do interesting films work with
interesting people and you know that's
because you get to a certain point you
say what are you leaving behind and if
this movies like this I said great you
know it's something that has an effect
and that you know kind of has a you know
has a half-life that's a wonderful thing
doing the stand-up has another thing
that it seems to get affects people in a
way and to have access to both it's like
you know black said having passports to
many countries that I get the passport
to do the HBO and then get the passport
to do this and it takes people by
surprise but that's great so people keep
guessing rule number nine make your life
spectacular you know as we come to the
end of this phase of our life we find
ourselves trying to remember the good
times I'm trying to forget the bad times
and we find ourselves thinking about the
future we start to worry thinking what
am I gonna do
where am I gonna be in 10 years
[Music]
but I say to you hey look at me
please who worry so much because in the
end none of us have very long on this
earth
life is fleeting
and if you ever distressed cast your
eyes to the summer sky
the stars are strung across the velvety
night
when a shooting star streaks through the
blackness turning night and today
make-a-wish
think of me
make alive spectacular I know I did
[Music]
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is be an amazing
performer up until now I think Billy
Connolly who held the record for talking
longest without the question prompting
it
[Applause]
knowing that the two of your great
friends I wonder who stopped talking
first it's difficult to know you know
get up there on there people playing
dead cats you can't stop for me I get up
there Emma it's wild because he's just
it just goes you tell your stories at
the eternia ray and once I get off the
plane in Scotland I need subtitles
I could invent golf yeah they could have
a couple of Guinness and then the next
thing you know what here's my idea for a
sport a knuckleball into a gopher hole
I mean like to not forget - that was a
straight stick a little broken stick I
like a ball into a gopher hole oh you
mean like croquet kook a whole hundreds
of yards away
kind of like a bowling alley oh no way
getting away
on the way like T's and butchers whack
the ball and you're sitting there
whacking away and you feel like you're
gonna have a stroke we'll call it
because every time you hit the ball you
think you're gonna die right near the
end I'll put a nice flat bit with a tiny
flag to give you a hope put a pool and a
sandbox to grab your ball to do this one
time now I've got a special bonus tip
from Robert on how to master your craft
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
how can you make your life spectacular
number two how can you do something
interesting this week and number three
where do you need to just be more honest
with yourself the question is though
this which is wonderful manic stand-up
performer that go away this sort of
extraordinary flow of laughter and then
in the clip in the film do you play now
one hour photo Uli's very silent man
you're totally utterly planned yes and
face this almost yeah that was the
purpose to actually do the exact
opposite of what you've just seen your
mug incredibly well I think because I
could do what I've just done and what I
do on stage and have all of that energy
and then let all of that go and be this
man like you said who is almost faceless
who is so bland that he lives
vicariously through other people's
photographs and that's why I did it
to be in a movie that's kind of so
unsettling because of that stillness I
think and it takes people by surprise
which is good
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Jim Carrey check of the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
that I'm just making a conscious choice
to perceive challenges as something
beneficial so that I can deal with them
in the most productive way you'll come
up with your own style